el anuncio de ron de santis rompió el
internet el gobernador de Florida
anunció su candidatura a las elecciones
primarias del partido republicano a
través de Twitter spaces un foro de la
red social propiedad de elon musk que
reunió virtualmente a más de 300.000
personas lo que provocó que la
presentación tuviera múltiples
dificultades técnicas
Hay 318,000 personas en línea así que
vamos a ver
creo que tenemos un número masivo de
personas conectadas por lo que los
servidores están un poco tensos
en Miami decenas de personas con
consignas a favor de los derechos de la
comunidad
lgbtq y más y los afroamericanos
protestaron en contra de la candidatura
de su gobernador de santis ha sido un
duro crítico de lo que él ha llamado
ideología de género llegando a probar
una ley que prohíbe la enseñanza de los
conceptos relativos a la identidad de
género en escuelas públicas así como
otras políticas anti derechos según
analistas este tipo de políticas podrían
jugarle en contra en sus aspiraciones
presidenciales
donde de Santi se está tratando de
distinguirse es en hacerse ver como si
fuera un intérprete de la política más
calmado y quizás más serio que Trump
mucha gente incluidos Los partidarios de
Trump Están preocupados por su
imprudencia en el escenario nacional la
forma en que dice las cosas no parece
una opinión deseable del poder
estadounidense tanto en casa como en el
mundo
competirá con Donald Trump para hacer el
nominado del partido republicano para la
casa blanca el que salga ganador
intentará evitar la reelección del
presidente Joe biden en los comicios de